so what's the lids thing how does that
work do you know how Brian's eyes have
like how they have like they just look
like eyes complete well you know how
they have like the visor the skin - I
did see it until the dramatic turn no I
get it
look I got a lot of I got a lot of meat
over my eyes so what they do is they
just take the skin and I just told you
this told me to do it my mother did it
she goes people in our family because
you're legalized on I just get it done
before like so nobody notices get it
done when you're young so you don't get
it when you're 70 but by the time your
skin keeps going yes I know because then
I'm like this and I can't see it so the
insurance covers it because when people
like me you actually you're your vision
gets compromised so before that happens
on a validate you get that's a back
surgery that's a fact that's why
insurance covers it hmm because
otherwise you're now I'm going to Jason
diamond that's Kourtney Kardashian's
doctor my yeah so I'm gonna be beautiful
bring up Kourtney before and after for a
second plus the garden something diamond
now hold on hold on Jason diamond now
hold on
that's elective surgery no it's the
other one it's no show show who's the
other star - Chloe that's that's the
clone you watch this well you told I
mean she just came out recently with
this picture oh yeah that was like
making the rounds on Twitter yeah yeah
it's like it's like an entirely
different person come on Khloe
Kardashian accused of changed her face
was surgery health anyway he's accusing
her I think we're all like yep that's
what she did yeah and that I Got News
for you that was that was certainly go
to battle that went after when she was
like super thick this one like Rob with
a wig on no Mary versus before and after
Jim yeah no one's think about Rob how
the [ __ ] do they do that
how the halacha today she don't show on
the right she's a cow on the left no
don't say that she's a big girl
don't she doesn't eat grass and she's
she's she's she's fiercely handsome in
that left side and she's just like you'd
want her name girl line this game of
thrones I want it big strong girl and
then over here she did something I don't
know man that is I don't know
sell it hurry what's wrong like if you
have your money of it like she's yeah
drop-dead gorgeous on the right you know
so interesting is once you get big
enough you can make a drastic change to
your face like that and just pretend
like nothing happened
no you know you go into interviews and
it's like elephant in the room and like
no one addresses how to address it like
this is always been my favorite you want
to talk to me about my movie like
everyone knows the guys think is it's
the amount of filler and the amount of
like two-faced tightening and like what
you wouldn't face feel like in that's it
you're Kylie's the craziest that's nuts
I know I would say like Chloe's on par
with that that's like a lot of
renovation I don't know yeah that's nuts
dude well she had her lips definitely
the lips done thank dr. wonder she's got
a great face for it she had a good face
to be get a good job to begin with them
though when you're a surgeon you go
alright we've had a good starting point
I like the palate knows whatever genius
not that the chisel this off will narrow
this down the nose is genius though they
product just a little bit Wow
she's swallow hot now tits her ass a lot
of work do oh my god that's excessive
that was she what she looked like
you can't blame girls with all the
pressure they go under and all the fun
people and how at were the haters and
they're like [ __ ] this I'm just gonna
try to look beautiful when it's over
there what is Kylie Jenner plastic
surgery over there now down yeah the
what she's not a white chick pair white
it's gotta be tough though here like a
girl growing up and the burbs or
whatever and this is normalized and it's
just like this has become common you'll
get this please I'm in this town but
like over there it should be a different
standard you know what I mean like if
you're in Iowa you're like yeah not
gonna be able to do that dude that
doctor is a genius
seriously that's that's [ __ ] him
she's also a billionaire you know that
she's got a billion dollars cuz she
sells her makeup what are you doing a
brine huh what are you doing it when I
find a doctor they can make me look back
at that good doctor die
yeah your diamond I think June 16th
that's so yeah I gotta go do my what if
you coming out here he comes in and no
one notices
hey guys Buffy's like hugs your day
going what if he just looks surprised oh
hey I gotta go have a god-like chase I
gotta have a constellation cuz I gotta
make sure he knows this is what I watch
every podcast guess when he's looking at
it just what I want to look surprised
all the [ __ ] time
I can't wait together cuz I've been
doing this now I feel good papa
what about what about the the wrinkles
I'm not touch with my [ __ ] wrinkles
now I could go like this here's what you
get in trouble as a guy watch the whole
the back they pull it back now look
where my breasts are food you are League
of smooth them yeah I know I look like a
[ __ ] old guy who got plastic surgery
can't have that see that I have four
good eight hours sleep a little Botox
and the wrinkles hey they do with guys
my age I'm not doing Botox I will never
do Botox I will never do anything but my
[ __ ] lids your expression says your
moneymaker I remember so Gordon Ramsay
did Botox and he looked very very like
smooth afterwards
that's Brian at the wound hey Gordon
you're a stud you're you're a [ __ ]
giant man be a man the the earthworm jim
[ __ ] scales on his forehead are just
acting dude [ __ ] boys got some deep
lines yeah he's a pro soccer player he's
a [ __ ] giant oh did any hurt himself
and that's how he God knows your size be
big guy yeah he's part of the thick boys
bike club oh yeah
he's always he's a good guy he brings
the snacks ah yeah it is yeah it is
Lizzy had something done with his
[ __ ] eyes I can see more eyeball mmm
he had all the work done look at his
[ __ ] chin dude that's a strong chin
Baba yeah now is that that's from Botox
or filler I remember him saying
something about Botox and he looked very
different smooth after boathook him down
there is that even really him that looks
like a boxer he looks like a robber a
[ __ ] alien look at that yeah Wow so
maybe he had a real plastic surgery too
listen dude if I can if I can just look
a little less we just don't know what it
what it looked like we don't know what
Kylie's healing looks like when she's 60
now like social media we don't know I
always thought that it's not grow we
know what then all right we'll keep
going but I can happen plastic surgery
it looks great until it doesn't
it's like it's a gambling you're like
yeah I keep on the way thing you know
you don't know when to stop when in the
news it's bad yeah you do the last
procedure and you're like I tempted
failure that's why that this whatever
that Kardashian girl looks night and day
yeah but Wendy's if it's when didn't
work your whole levee break so every
three MS yeah every three to six months
they get filler they do all this filler
so basically yeah so what they do it the
jaw is they'll del they shoot filler in
your jaw to make it more pronounced okay
I don't know what they do with like the
bones maybe they have a way to shave the
bones that I don't [ __ ] know I would
imagine they do but that when you
rephrase if they gave her curves yeah
chin didn't you get Botox yeah for the
the mandible area Massa ders why did
Saad bruxism you know when you wouldn't
that you grind your teeth too much it
from the sleeper what yeah
and that my teeth are actually cracked
on block like top and bottom so did that
and then it's slender do I even though
my face doesn't look that slender it's
lighted up a ton this side in this side
these are huge muscles right here how
much I want to do something well
couldn't you just do have a mouth garden
or like a night guard I could have but
it's such a simple last way to do it you
know the question is one is Brian gonna
go on testosterone uh-huh the other
question is when is Brian going to
[ __ ] is he gonna get his lids done
there are a lot of questions no you're
getting your lids done yeah if you I
think you while you're there previewing
it yeah just test driving it I can see
Oh daddy's eyes are getting bad I think
they look good told you hey Brett are
you a victim of cyberbullying right now
yeah I get a lot of women are like don't
get your lids done then I guess I'd be
like hey rinks get those [ __ ] eyes
caught me in the comments so you agree
no just my dams my dams that's a
passionate troll when they hit you up in
the DM is like all this guy cares i
following if it's a con man as many
eminent DM is like kenny for know me i
got a
he needs to see this we love your leg if
you wanted to pull you aside and let you
know go first he goes hey big fan then
once you accept and they go [ __ ] you
you've changed my life
psych you [ __ ] suck doctor you need
to quit gotcha screenshot yeah
is that it that's it my specially table
there you go look at the jaw now now
that I am no I I can't look at a face in
LA without an eye we can do you think
dr. Don could just take the puffiness
out of my face I don't think it happens
but you got I think it suck it no you
got to do take skin from he did kylie
jenner's [ __ ] transformation he can't
hook your boy up be a man you're you're
manly just be manly hmm now you be manly
the only thing I would do I've told you
my nose the only thing I've a good nose
what do you mean no don't watch but
watch it could I have why I have a good
[Music]
tuck the ears we can do this you know
touch my sack do this or we can do what
I personally like my grandma so maybe
pull it back pull it back should show
dr. diamond if you I just take a little
on my face oh that's good no that's nice
Brendan Kardashian over here I think I
look like the guy from don't [ __ ] with
cats Oh
Luka Magnotta huge like I watched that
whole documentary and then I was getting
my reference at The Comedy Store and I
was like I'm gonna do an impression some
of you might know this I mean might not
I don't know what it is but uh I go hi
I'm Luca mcnaught oo5 returned I can
take my shirt off if you guys need me to
three people were like loving
audition video right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]